man [ __ ] dave matthews i can't stand
those [ __ ] looking at my bare
foot and [ __ ]
that [ __ ] drives me crazy those [ __ ]
oh yeah get the [ __ ] out yeah we got a
bait we got a black guy playing banjo
barefoot him and the [ __ ] fallout
boys they had the balls to say yesterday
we we want to do our music before we
become dinos listen
these dinosaurs will take you and rip
you apart you [ __ ] idiots what's the
last good song fallout boy but did do
you know lee cause i know you like that
music i have no idea no you don't be
[ __ ] lying to me you went to see
hunger games part two you like that
music it was a decent movie i know i had
to talk them into doing edibles you know
to talk me it it was a tuesday night why
are you going to go straight yeah and
put up with that [ __ ] nonsense
straight go [ __ ] eat some stars and
he [ __ ] listened good man what's her
name you were were you blasting one out
to uh what's her name jennifer uh oh
jennifer she's hot she's hot huh she's
kind of crazy in these though yeah she
doesn't really look sick
you know who i saw a picture of is uh
what's her name [ __ ]
jennifer aniston no whoopi goldberg
sarah silverman
at the premiere for a movie did you see
that picture i didn't know she was so
hot oh no she dresses up when she
dresses up it's like a whole different
person i've never seen that before it's
unbelievable sarah salmon's a good
looking little [ __ ] beautiful she
always dresses down and i've never seen
them
have you seen it yeah what i mean
the pictures what [ __ ] picture
put that down a little bit what picture
the at her premiere who's premiere sarah
silverman she's got a new movie out oh
sarah does yeah a little indie film okay
i didn't know nothing yeah [ __ ] he's
talking about hunger games
people were talking about oscar
nominations and [ __ ] yeah really good
she did a really good job
you know she's one of those people
that's been around forever she's like a
she's like aids she won't go away she
can't stop it you know she's been around
with you know when i came to this town
she had just popped in something about
mary
even though she was just sitting at a
whole table listening she was involved
in that movie that was a great [ __ ]
movie my ass on
but she won't go away she's always stays
relevant you know she always pops she
popped a great hbo special last year
yeah it wasn't as much as great as how
she did it at largo yeah
and all that type of stuff so she does
it her own way she's like joey diaz well
how you actually gonna do it i got
nobody you know i got nobody's way to do
it there's the only way you can do it
yeah what's up irish good to see you man
[ __ ] thanksgiving thanksgiving i've
been holding that all week i've been
thinking about [ __ ] pumpkin pies like
last saturday like
like by last thursday you're like man i
can't hold that no more i need a [ __ ]
piece of pumpkin pie i'm smoking this
high cap i never got into the pumpkin
that's my favorite thing in the world
a little bit of whipped cream on top
heat that [ __ ] up oh and you
know what i hated pumpkin pie as a kid
yeah i liked like [ __ ] colors like
boysenberry and apple but when i went to
catholic school i got stuck with a
pumpkin pie once oh my god how [ __ ]
good are those yeah and the cheaper the
better right give me that those oven
ones you can cut up oh my [ __ ] godly
with some cool whip
cool i'm not even real whipped cream no
no no not cool with the real [ __ ] the
can okay real whip i don't think i'm
cool with that tub of [ __ ] i'll go buy
i'll go to a bodega and buy one of those
little intense pies the one the size of
your fist you pop it right out of there
i've always wondered what those are the
little pie fillings they're little pie
fillings it's just like a little mini
pie
7-eleven it's exactly a pie but it's the
size of your fist and if you're between
meals and it'll pick me up you grab
yourself an edmonds pie
apple they'll throw it in the microwave
for you
really pop it out of the tin thing throw
it in the microwave
i never ate one of those yeah that's
great
i don't know what the [ __ ] that is it's
scary like anton men's you never heard
of them
i heard of but they have a little apple
pie yeah a little out every pie it's on
the counter like next to the this is how
fat i was i know what you're talking
about and it's next like those little
donuts but it's just like pie filling i
was always too scared to get it i don't
know what the [ __ ] that is i didn't know
if you had to bake it or something i'm
always going to host this apple pie type
really that was part of my game growing
up that's a quick filler that's just
nothing but glazed yeah it's glazed with
a [ __ ] can of coke oh yeah oh my god
the dentist is like that's my boy [ __ ]
that's my [ __ ] right there
that's money in the bank oh my god i
love you you see him unloading the truck
out back your dentist you know now you
eat that hostess that's [ __ ]
horrendous
that food is all horrendous they've
taken chemicals out they've added
chemicals in remember to host this
cupcake just the plain chocolate with
the little [ __ ] thing yeah the little
swirl a little swirl they gave you like
a little heavy little dot of [ __ ]
sperm in there yeah now they give you
nothing it's like some [ __ ] little
[ __ ] with the head
shoots a little gun in there with a
little [ __ ] little you got to eat 10
pounds of chocolate to get to a little
[ __ ] hippie sperm that's one drop
yeah it's going to be the whole load you
get the whole [ __ ] load of sperm in
there from the guy at the factory no
nothing some skinny guy coughing who
eats
i used to be like a guy a diabetic blew
a hot thick one inside of a cupcake
[ __ ] torment those things were you
know when you're from the east coast you
grow up on those things and everybody's
different i think like south jersey has
tasty cakes in philadelphia up by me i
was more of uh
what did i like i liked the
ring dings
the rest of the country called them ding
dongs
i'm a devil dog type of [ __ ]
but my all-time favorite was the yo-yos
the chocolate with the cream filled up
like that and you got two in the package
and then they got dipped in chocolate to
boot that's diabetics right there yeah
yeah another one the dentist is right
there tap on you on the back
give me a twinkie you take the
cellophane off the little top gets stuck
on it you get to scrape that off with
your teeth
they tried to stop making twinkies and
people
lost their [ __ ]
they picketed they protest they wrote
letters they brought it back
i got hooked on twinkies one night
twinkies was the first sugar buzz i had
because my mom
i would go to my mom and go mom i'm
going on a school trip and instead of
just buying me two twinkies she'd buy me
a box and say sharon with your friends
[ __ ] you
[ __ ] you you would hoard the snacks
listen i would start eating those
twinkies at 11 o'clock at night the
night before before the odd couple
i remember the first all-nighter i
pulled on twinkies one all-nighter on
twitter
and instead of snorting like when you do
blow you do like blurry 20 minutes when
you pull along lightly [ __ ]
guys this is the funniest [ __ ] story
of all time
i pulled an all-nighter on twinkies one
day
before we went to philadelphia and where
betsy ross did the [ __ ] letter yeah
where's she the letter the way she made
the flags what the [ __ ] yeah and we went
to see the nutcracker suite
my mother bought a box of those a box or
something else and a box of something
else
and it was the first addictive
personality that i ever showed i did not
know it then
i thought about it years later
how i kept watching him you know i
started with the our couple ah the
honeymoon he's another twinkie then uh
the octopus the twilight zone i gotta
have a twinkie for the twilight zone
and this time i'm gonna get two and some
milk to dilute them it's a one hour yeah
it's a one hour we gotta get two
and then at one i watched something else
i had hbo when i was a kid so i watched
something else yeah you know hbo was
brand new oh hbo late at night
frank went out no you in the late movie
when i was a young man seven when that
happened not not when i was seven
when i that happened i was in the eighth
grade so i'm talking about 78 the hot
movie at the time they kept playing that
you'd whack off two was
kentucky fried movie or the groove tube
the group had a chick that ran across
naked with her titties and you had that
big box with three levels
and that's how you got channels in those
days so each one had one to seven seven
to twenty one and twenty one that's
right that was it that was it guys that
was cable [ __ ] tv
and it had a string connected to the tv
so you had let's say that that's a tv
you had a string with a box on it and
then they had like levels
so you had zero to seven seven to
fourteen and fourteen to twenty one
[ __ ] tremendous hbo was eighteen hbo
is 18 and you compress it that's how you
did it you pressed the [ __ ] hbo and
you got all excited nobody was around
and that's the first thing i [ __ ]
whacked it it was like oh yeah yeah but
i remember being six in the morning and
still eating those twinkies and being
jazzed up and not knowing
what's going on in your life like just
being jazzed up and going why do i feel
this way right and being awake the whole
[ __ ] day and years later
one night i'm sitting there think
talking to somebody and they're like
yeah remember that trip and i'm like
yeah
the night before was the most
interesting night of my life because i
stayed up all night
eating twinkies they're like [ __ ] yeah
you did if you ate the whole box of
twinkies
that'll keep you up all [ __ ] right at
that age yeah getting coked up on
twinkies
like sucking a dick one after the other
little little brown little brown twinkie
dicks and ever since that time you know
what
if i'm high and i gotta eat a twinkie
yeah i'll eat it but i don't think i
think since that eighth grade i think
i've had two twinkies yeah in 50 years
40 years you had your quota two seconds
what's up i i have to unplug and plug
this mic back in what's going on
for you two i think it's just him but
we'll check all right no something's
going on here last week we had the
echoes so we just want to double check
for you people at home and [ __ ] like
that
there you go pop that back in boom
[ __ ] it check check check check check
now we got nothing nothing at all oh
wait there we go there you go there you
go lisa yeah you're slipping [ __ ]
sucking i just haven't seen him [ __ ]
go ahead but those are the i don't know
if that's
what else did you remember growing up in
boston
new york i grew up in new york and what
were you eating as a child after you
left because you always ate something at
home right but then once you were
halfway home if you were a fat [ __ ]
those are marshmallow pies
it was these candy bars called the
marathon bar and it was like it was
straight with strings of caramel covered
in chocolate and then twisted into a
braid
and you you you [ __ ] you took a bite
of that and your salivary glands opened
up like the hoover dam it just your
saliva attacked this piece of chocolate
heaven and you chewed the [ __ ] out of it
because it wasn't like the new caramel
where it just it's goo and slides down
your throat this was caramel you had to
earn
you you wear at your jaw chewing on this
[ __ ] and the chocolate is mixing in with
it and the saliva is mixed in and you
swallow it and you got to take a break
before the next bite you got to give
your jaws a couple seconds between sets
and they take another bite and you know
that that's a workout that was good 15
20 minutes to eat the marathon bar
do you guys remember whoopi pies
whoopie pies are the best those are
stuff
so you know that thing those chocolate
caramel that's a good training thing for
young [ __ ] like when they're 18
you got them into the festival listen
before you can get anybody got to suck
on these for a month
so you really get a good job no but i'm
ready to suck a dick no you're not yeah
yeah
it's a matter of second dick is a
marathon it's a completely different
situation you just you know you've just
been blowing you know [ __ ] guys in
high school we're taking that to the
major leagues we're trying to get we're
trying to get the big 200 out of these
guys
the guys in high school they just could
they couldn't believe their dick was in
their mouth yeah
there was no effort you know i never
even got a [ __ ] in high school from a
girl i never even thought it from
anything
from anything
nothing i never would even consider
a woman giving me a [ __ ] never
because they're all good catholic girls
i just didn't i never thought i'd have
the balls hey to ask a woman
b
if i heard a woman suck dick i would
avoid her
like the [ __ ] plague in those days i
don't know what it was like i never
thought
ever ever ever if i had to think back to
my first blow job it's got to be about
19.
i was working uh security for a guy
louie donato on a massage paul up on
91st street and [ __ ] kennedy
boulevard up there
louie diana was his half wannabe [ __ ]
mobster guy that talked a big game
so he had a couple girls and he had like
four ships four different guys at
different times we were all friends and
you guys were security for two horses i
could get beat up any time in those days
there was like four wars in that and one
night on a saturday he goes hey man uh
i'll give you 50 bucks and pick one of
the girls to blow you
and i picked this redhead and i was
[ __ ] [ __ ] my pants like i was
just [ __ ] my pants i started going
in that room and just being like i
didn't know what to expect
i'll never forget she took a piece of
gum out of her mouth and put it on the
[ __ ] table before she blew me
it was the most impersonal thing
to her
it was the most impersonal situation
you know what i'm saying like yeah
yeah if that was my tent blow job i
could
feel it but in the back of your mind you
always think your first blow job is
gonna be this [ __ ] thing with angels
and and birds are getting shot out into
the sky and you hear voices that never
did
that should never happen for me you know
it was like my first [ __ ] was just
the opposite it was this girl linda and
she was a great girl but she'd been
she'd been around town you know she was
confident big tits she called him pride
and joy
and she said to me for my 16th birthday
she was going to give me the best
[ __ ] i would ever have in my life
and she came over my house
parents were out it's april it's a nice
spring day i remember the windows open
little breeze coming in linda comes up
to my room
and she takes my pants down herself i
try to take him off she stops me she
takes them off
then she takes the underwear off and
then she works it i mean she's i didn't
know that a blow job included ball
licking that that was an option
i didn't know that it's circled i didn't
know that there was two hands could be
cranked on the base a decent size and uh
and she worked it and there was eye
contact there was intent eye contact
throughout
checking in
she wanted to know how i was doing every
second i'd be so [ __ ] embarrassed oh
it was unbelievable
post-coital i cuddled with her after the
[ __ ]
and i feel for you joey that that that
had to be your first blow job i gotta
ask you something
where is she today
she has kids and she lives a couple
towns over from where we grew up i think
she did well i think she married well
you still keep in touch with them from
time to time sending a little facebook
it's always good
to hit one of those freaks on facebook
and give him like a little reminder yeah
i have one i'm working now not because i
want to sleep but i'm not just because
she was such a savage and such an animal
yeah
and now she's got a kid but i want to
remind her that she's such an animal
so i do i post this new jersey first of
all the last time i had seen this girl
was when doug flutie threw the touchdown
okay and it was just a horror show i
robbed louis donato at this time she was
louie's boss he was louie's
uh
what is that nanny
and i saw her at corki's and this [ __ ]
had a body
they called her laurie jack because they
said you know in those days she's got
the jack yeah everybody said she had
some ac dc wrote a song called she's got
the jack
which implied she had like aids not aids
at that time but like gonorrhea clinton
chlamydia and all that no there wasn't
even chlamydia in 79 79 it was just
syphilis
and something came out of your dick
that's it all of a sudden over the years
they've added all these dimensions and
names to throw you off yeah it all
started with funk the head of your dick
swells up
blood comes out you know what i'm saying
the nuts are purple you go crazy yeah
you got good ones you go crazy oh my god
you sit there and go what did i [ __ ]
what type of animal did i [ __ ] what
planet is she from yeah and i'll tell
you something knock on wood i could be
honest on this show it never happened to
me i just shut up
i had crabs
i've gotten crabs
and then i was [ __ ] around with these
dirty college girls when you mess around
with college girls bro you're always
gonna get something you're [ __ ] the
whole campus yeah you get foot fungus
something i had this
i had this little leakage coming out of
my helmet yeah and then i noticed that
both of them like when i was sleeping
with one for a while and then she moved
and i started sleeping with the other
one
both of them had this like white leakage
yeah from their little monkey it was
chlamydia but i wasn't going to
embarrass him and tell him i just get
wiped and kept eating that ass you know
what i mean
this got nothing to do with uncle joey
it's like finding a hair in your
hamburger yeah get rid of it eating that
[ __ ] you know people send the hamburger
back come on before you send them
hamburger back think back to how many
[ __ ] you licked
you ever get these [ __ ] i was
hearing my food come in let me talk to
you
you take the hair out and you proceed
you're gonna send the sandwich back and
now they're gonna spit in it
you know because that's what you do when
somebody says
what's wrong with hair let me put a
[ __ ] coke snack from tuesday in that
[ __ ] wait till you crunch into
that and think it's a grape
i got a hemorrhoid oh yeah i'm going to
rub the hemorrhoid on your french fries
not even you take you squeeze the
hemorrhoid you get that hemorrhoid juice
it's like that black [ __ ] tart it
comes out they think it's romalay sauce
these [ __ ] jerk [ __ ] gentiles
but that [ __ ] drives me crazy when
people act like that oh well you know
they'll stop yeah they [ __ ] [ __ ]
no and i i don't even like the guy that
uh has them pour a half a glass of wine
pour the [ __ ] wine and drink the wine
what are you gonna drink you're gonna
take a sip from half a glass and swish
it around and then say no i'm sorry
caesar wants you caesar wants you to
bring forth another glass of [ __ ] you
i got to tell you guys you know what my
mom bought some wine this week she's out
for thanksgiving she went to ralph's and
bought some wine and next night i come
home and i go mom what do you got five
ice cubes in your wine for she goes it's
[ __ ] wine and it's like buy another
[ __ ] bottle of wine she was like nah
finish this one club w but here's the
crazy thing
that culture never was sold to me
okay lee you're a very young man
my man irish is younger than i am i came
from a culture
family affair courtship of eddie's
father uh room two two two
combat you know all those shows when men
had a conversation
in the 60s and 70s in the early 60s late
60s and 70s on television
on cbs nbc or cboa with abc when three
two men had a conversation
there was always a bottle on the table
with no label on it there was a bucket
with ice cubes with frog
and as soon as two men walked in a room
what are we gonna do about the diaz
situation well i the first thing i did
in this late 60s and early 70s was to
turn around
okay without even eye contact without
offering
you didn't even offer in this time in
the united states you turned around you
took two glasses you'd put an ice cube
in each right on tv while the camera was
rolling
and he was saying his stupid [ __ ]
lines about how the world's gonna end
and
if the russians don't go out to the
fallout shelter and they'd always pour
from the bottle which you assume was
whiskey correct always do you remember
this is a young man yeah something right
and they gave it to everybody and
everybody
they didn't go cheers or salud
they just drank it and they discussed
their situation and throughout the show
drinking was always acceptable yeah as a
young man
for for me for me that made my dick hard
my mom had a bar you know what next week
when i go down there i'm gonna get a
[ __ ] drink with an ice cube how old
are you at this point five six
you know me dawg it looks cool i
understand it looks [ __ ] tremendously
cool
what kid doesn't gets one kid doesn't
look at that and go
i can't wait to be [ __ ] 18 to do that
to drink a [ __ ] shot i remember being
a kid we had these shrimp cocktail
glasses my parents would buy a six pack
of shrimp cocktails from the like
right remember those that you're washing
them out
you wash them out you keep the glasses
and it's about the size of a scotch
glass so i remember me and my brother
says we put one ice cube in we put some
coca-cola on top and we'd walk around
the house like we were in [ __ ] mad
men
no [ __ ] sipping it
sipping it you know and then we'd roll
up pieces of paper my parents my dad
smoked three and a half packs a day we'd
roll up pieces of paper we'd dangle them
out of our mouths and we'd drink coke
with an ice cube there you go america so
you were
i don't know it was like alcoholism was
acceptable okay whatever now my mom had
a bar
i got drunk one time shipped my pants
they found me in a closet that was the
end of my alcoholism career
did you know that that was it that was
it my mom had a thing before she'd go to
bed she'd do a little shot of wine i
sculpt the [ __ ] red italian wine
once she fell asleep i went
i drank the whole bottle of wine my mom
got up jose antonio jose antonio no jose
antonio she dialed 9-1-1 the cops came
they found me in the closet puke [ __ ]
all over the place how old are you four
five
that was the end of my alcoholism career
right that's it that's it no more
everything that was [ __ ] on my feet they
had to put me in the tub i slept for two
days
you know it's always been a [ __ ]
disaster and that was it and you never
drank since no i've i've tried i [ __ ]
tried i've tried
tried jack i loved everything i loved
everything then when you do cocaine
you know it's like uh it's like a gin
it's like an indian without gin yeah you
know a line of coke requires alcoholism
so
i did that but when i became 18
something really weird happened i
started hanging out with people i
thought they were johnny bananas
i had a friend that if he drank a
whiskey he had to have a certain glass
yeah and that [ __ ] never bought it to me
then i went out to dinner with the
holloway it's the holloways with a
badass irish german family there you go
i speak to timmy every two days in fact
he's a truck driver he listens and he'll
remember this when we graduated in high
school
mr holloway took us out to dinner can't
remember the place in hoboken
we're all [ __ ] sitting there eating
and mr holloway oh there's a bottle of
dinner mr holloway liked a few drinks
but he had a rule
boys
you come to my house you can eat every
day you can curse in my house you can
watch sports can't drink in my house
that was our rule
both my parents huge drinkers you didn't
drink in the house do me that favor
respect me right
uh you know we'd go every time we went
anywhere we'd always stop at mr
holloway's house and get tuned up he
would get more money the best was when
mr holloway was on the couch sleeping
years later we come in at three in the
morning we're making sandwiches to go
into a disco in the city
and as we walk past and mr holloway
turns on he goes what to go you know i
mean
we used to torment them yeah but
i forget the [ __ ] story i was going
to tell you who the [ __ ] knows we're
talking about those uh you know
shrimp cocktail glasses
and we were talking about it and we went
to dinner and all of a sudden some guy
comes by and he goes you know
excuse me uh
caviar sauvignon blanc 68
and you know and all of a sudden he
opens the bottle and he's got like a
thing and he [ __ ] i think he drinks a
little and he spits down it
and i'll never forget he goes to mrs
holloway and he goes to mr holloway
and he gets to roger and little roger's
crazy we're crazy at the time we're
[ __ ] crazy
little roger looks and goes give me the
[ __ ] bottle
hey just give me the [ __ ] bottle and
that was the end of that in my life i
knew that i wasn't the only one who
thought that way yeah a glass is a glass
yeah i don't give a [ __ ] what glass i
don't have a [ __ ] wine glass and the
whole [ __ ]
serenade with the sweater on my
shoulders to have a [ __ ] drink of
wine all right i know people who are
broke that [ __ ] drink wine out of a
bottle having to have a great time
have a [ __ ] great time with the same
alcohol kind of same alcohol i never
understood the whole glassware
yeah the whole thing when i've snorted
coke i've drank [ __ ] gasoline
out of a rock glass it don't matter no i
mean you got a you gotta you got an ass
hair on your hamburger or some wine to
taste a little bit fruity suck it up and
don't waste everybody's [ __ ] time
we're trying we're trying to go out
we're trying to get this done so we can
do the next thing we can't do the next
thing if you're sending [ __ ] one
ounce little sifters of wine back i
won't have it i won't have it i i don't
even care if my [ __ ] is too raw
i eat around it so it's always just that
one little
red chunk in the middle of your steak so
you eat around it eat everything else
but don't don't send it back
that [ __ ] embarrasses me to know when
you know what i do when the food sucks
right i pay the bill i get up and i
leave yeah
and i i make a mental i get in the car
and i call this [ __ ] dude and i tell
him don't go to the food sucked well i
went there last tuesday get the [ __ ] in
the [ __ ] stock
it tastes like gas
did he say taste like gas or taste like
ass ass ass
you know i'm not even sure what which
place you're talking about any [ __ ]
place i'm just saying i mean that's the
first thing you do i'm not gonna sit
there and argue with you
and go back and forth you know right or
wrong i'm in indianapolis recently [ __ ]
in the bed at some club in the suburbs
nobody's coming it's like i've got the
hiv
and so uh i'm miserable all weekend and
then i go you know it's saturday night
in between shows i'm gonna go next door
they got a sushi restaurant i'm gonna
get a nice plate of sushi cheer up a
little bit spend a few bucks live
so
i go there between shows and i order i
get some miso soup and some sushi miso
soup comes out it's ice cold it's as
salty as a [ __ ] shot from a guy that just
walked 40 days in the desert oh no then
i get the and so i don't eat it and then
all of a sudden they bring the sushi and
it's like it had been smoked like the
corners of the fish were dry and curled
back it had been sitting there for days
meanwhile the way to recognize me so i
walk and he goes greg fitzsimmons holy
[ __ ] he goes i'm going to take great
carry it's like if you want to take care
of me get some [ __ ] takeout from
another restaurant because this [ __ ] is
poison
so he puts it in front of me and i don't
want to be a douche because he
recognized me so i don't
so i just uh
so i just uh i gave him a big [ __ ]
tip and like you said i just walked out
i wasn't gonna eat that [ __ ]
first of all shame on you
for going to a sushi place next door to
indianapolis i mean how many [ __ ]
people left hiroshima
to go to indianapolis okay
you know so shame on you it's like you
don't leave wall schwitz to move to
ireland open a bagel shop you've already
been in torture for 40 [ __ ] years
you leave auschwitz to go to new york
and get the party started
how the [ __ ] did you connect those two
thoughts
because i've been smoking weed to take
this morning it doesn't matter is it
like in world war ii thought
these bagels are good yeah my family's
all dead enjoy it
i hope the bagel cheers yup
tremendous happy thanksgiving
[ __ ] this is what life is all
about just
sometimes just getting a stupid laugh
man
and this guy's over here humming like a
cat what the [ __ ] is wrong with you in
the corner just humming like again
oh my god
you
and it's time for another inhaler this
inhaler brought to you by asthma
boy they can't stop thinking of ways to
get [ __ ] pot in your system anybody
else no no
you're wiping your nose you drop it in
your eye anybody come up with the eye
drops yet that's got to be next that's
the next one the cannabis eye drops i'm
sure they have them i gotta hit acid
here if you want to take it home for
later to go right i'm good thanks right
down that little doorknob look at you i
got three hidden up there well don't
tell them where they're hanging well i'm
not gonna tell nobody where they are
they're gonna come here with the dog
acid that feels like 1979. that's what
bringing it back
listen man
in the words of public enemy
if you don't know about your past you
don't know your future you gotta take
care of the acid from time to time and
take you back there just to dibble a
little bit all right what do you do once
you take the acid you gotta stay indoors
we stayed here and we did a podcast with
me lee and ari shafir eddie bravo came
to mediate he didn't get high and we
just giggled with you like five [ __ ]
you three took the acid that for five
hours just fine no you did a five-hour
podcast we did a three-hour podcast two
and a half years and a half three and
then we were [ __ ] we sat here for an
hour after that just sweating
sweating giggling and
yeah didn't i send you a video of the
mexican guy taking his clothes off now
come on
so we're here i call duncan you know
duncan likes drugs i call duck and i go
dunking you want to come to the park to
do last night i can't
you know i i have other plans okay no
worries you have to [ __ ] come
so i call hari hari who's going to come
anyway i just want to have a couple
people
so duncan sits at home and he's watching
this [ __ ] podcast
in the middle of the podcast he decides
to send me this [ __ ] now we're three
we're two hours in we're burning is this
last week this is about a month six
weeks ago we're burning
look at that marshmallow body holy i
feel good about my body right now oh
don't do it oh christ
holy christ greg you're sitting there
two hours ago
by yourself
it's like bobby lee the mexican i'm
gonna send you this how's that yeah
please show this to your mom tomorrow
everybody's sitting around show this one
on thanksgiving day
here's what i'm thankful for mom this
gentleman right here who has no body
shame and yet we all have body shame for
him
he doesn't give a [ __ ] he taped that he
probably puts on the dating service yeah
and sent that out to them so let's give
it away any replies oh
i would reply just to stab him
right or wrong i take him to a secluded
place like if i was single and gay and
crazy
and i'm just living life by the seat of
my pants oh he's a ghana
he's a ghana he's just like i'm like
what's that guy on tv that was killing
people and then
klexter leg dexter you immediately
became a gay serial killer why not think
about it if i'm [ __ ] gay and i'm part
of a [ __ ] day gate in sight yeah and
i'm sitting at home i had a bad week and
i can't find the job my last date the
guy wouldn't suck my dick he was a good
piece of ass but he gave him a bad blow
job you know
i'm sitting there i'm gay or as [ __ ] i'm
at home watching something on netflix
getting worked up go go tv and this guy
pops up on your screen yeah you just got
to think about this as soon as th this
video ends first thought that comes to
your mind is how many bullets do i have
do i have a rubber sheet this is going
to be fun no it doesn't have fun do i
have to go to mexico for this there is
no this guy lives in sherman oaks i
guarantee this guy lives in bitcoin but
this guy lives right under your nose you
see this guy when you go to rob some
wave after yeah he's behind the counter
he's lonely he's just looking for
another hemophiliac what's he that he
didn't have a dick he'd have a [ __ ]
what do you call those people he will
feel you and her
that means you can't stop bleeding that
means you're going to stab him once you
can walk away what happened to those
people when we were kids there's no more
right now there's no more hemophilia
they're gone yeah they disappeared
people things changed what happened to
the hemophilia
hemophilia was uh
you know i think people started saying
homophilia
and uh they changed it it became gay
guys to bleed a lot
that was my joke that's terrible
you want to edit that out lee no [ __ ]
though leave that oh you just sent me
the video i can't wait oh my god that's
hysterical that is that's what i'm
saying that could be any guy that but
they probably got that from a dating
site yeah
that's a dating site in mexico video
right you're at home in mexico you could
kill some people absolutely you get that
the thing yeah for yourself i got the
car i got the drop cloth uh-huh i got
everything yeah if you could kill
somebody how would you do it
it just depends what they did
yeah like it depends what they did i
have evil thoughts
that run through my mind you know i
really do you yeah and we all do we all
are mad at one or two people that we
think
disrespected us
disrespected themselves because they
[ __ ] with us yeah you know and uh
it crosses you when i was a kid i would
like my stepdad in the worst way
and i was going to get really good with
weapons and my plan was my genius plan
was to hide under a car and pop out and
shoot him and then you know i was always
good with escape routes you'd be
surprised escape rats like how to get
out of a city like if you shoot somebody
here you're not
you know you're gonna you're gonna
[ __ ] look around this area for a
while you're gonna see but today you
have drones
you have google map you have all these
things that they could go back
i could go back and see if you ever
walked in that neighborhood a year ago
do you know that yeah that's reality i
could really go back
it costs money
it's gonna cost you money we were
talking about this last week two months
ago at the comedy store kids sitting at
the door busy sunset [ __ ] boulevard
okay
kid walks up to ten to one takes out a
gun and shoots him seven times runs down
the hill gets in the car they've never
heard or seen from the guy
uh who wants a documentary it's been on
all week it's a brand new documentary
about
i watched bits and pieces
the tupac biggie march the penguins no
the tupac biggie murders how that right
i came how would they get it oh i got to
see that there was a south side crypt
that it was it was definitely [ __ ]
biggie uh it was definitely puff daddy
that put the order out that's what the
movie says
this documentary has the south side
crips
uh a million dollar bounty the bounty
got put at gold blots
right next to the laugh factory right
that's what they would eat in those days
like gold blotch green blots whatever
green blacks name of it
and listen right now there's two murders
take a look at you have to be a [ __ ]
[ __ ] if you're gonna murder somebody
number one
look at all the people that get caught
you know how come they get caught
because they tell somebody or they have
two or three people involved you're
gonna ice somebody gonna ice them
yourself
and the ices that we've seen look at the
[ __ ] best ices that you see look at
this thing at the common store
sixteen fifteen people on a patio cops
on la cienega
when people hear bullets
they go crazy
they don't see you don't see no more and
there was no camera no camera even with
the [ __ ] camera i got a hood on with
my thing around me
it's tough now yeah it's it's [ __ ]
tough yeah don't get me wrong look at
they got the 44 caliber killer with a
[ __ ] ticket
yeah you do make mistakes with a [ __ ]
uh
a parking ticket but look at all these
mob guys we think they're physicists
these guys shot people every night of a
car took them to a [ __ ] deserted
place buried them put lie on them make
the body disappear quicker
and they built construct these people
you know for every
300 murders sammy the bull said that
they were out there there's another 300
100 people that are out there that
nobody ever knew about yeah
went missing they went playing cards one
night
got into it with some [ __ ] like the
guy that played tommy and goodfellas
they just pull a gun out and shoot you
and it'll be scary in the room now you
know they make a big scene they put you
in a tablecloth and that [ __ ] totally
random that [ __ ] happened and
so you have to think about how you would
do it the person how would you do it no
but in terms of enjoyment for you
what would what would feel best to you
there's only one person
under god's eye that i would like to
chop into [ __ ] pieces that's how you
do it chop them up oh no no no no no no
no no no no no no no there's some people
that you shoot in the [ __ ] head yeah
because they deserve to get shoot in the
head there's some people that you're
shooting the [ __ ]
and watching
upwards i'll put it straight up and you
watch them live for four hours
giggling for their [ __ ] life
you can shot the [ __ ] you giggle with
a [ __ ] 32 you just shot up the ass
nothing to blow their heads off or not
just something to keep that hot bullet
in their [ __ ]
do you put the gun up the [ __ ] just a
little bit just just a little bit just
the crown you put a condom on the
[ __ ]
gun to make sure this guy's not a freak
you don't want your gun with the hips
you know what i'm saying you don't want
to go with the hip you can't get rid of
that guy
safe killing
you got to do safe killing so what's
your favorite gun but i figure if under
god's eye if anything ever bad happened
to me in my life
you'd have to realize that this is the
way i'd want to go out yeah as i go grab
that [ __ ] person
first of all it'd be documentation
okay there'd have to be documentation
because i have to make too many moves
i would scope them out for a few days i
would get really [ __ ] hungry and
angry
i would probably pick them off off the
[ __ ] street and have a cave
predetermined on an apartment and just
gag them and start the process
like the whole like uh what was that
fiction gerard butler movie
like a citizen what was that movie he
did ball in the mouth duct tape duct
taped hands
and first i start with punches for like
an hour yeah an hour for like an hour
i'm just gonna work out first of all go
to the pharmacy and get a couple ivs to
keep him alive for a few [ __ ] days
that's nice of you he's not gonna be
able to eat because you knocked all his
teeth out huh he's not gonna be able to
chew no gotta go iv let them have teeth
yeah and you just punch them for an hour
and then you hit them with sticks oh my
gosh then you rock them to death for a
little while what's that you rocking
like
like i ran
like i ran
then you kick them again
but you keep them alive that's the whole
you want them to suffer like you did
yeah
then you torment them you eat a few
sandwiches in front of them
maybe some twinkies
torment somebody you put a [ __ ] gun
up that [ __ ] or gun that dick and play
with them and ask them questions how's
that feel that feeling they're [ __ ]
good to you now
and then after about 12 hours of that
mental torch is when you really start
this [ __ ] then i go into iceman mode
yeah that's why i just take a razor
blade and start doing little paper cuts
everywhere just for about two hours
i'd probably faint two times because i
can't see blood so i gotta come back
this is why this is just a fantasy
ladies and gentlemen i'd be fainting by
now
but after i'd [ __ ] chop them up with
that razor blade for about two or three
hours and rub that juice salt on them
that's sea salt i'd rub them in sea salt
like a chicken collard you understand me
i'd roll them in that sea salt and
there's no worse pain than that guys
then if they were a woman i'd take a
razor blade and slit that [ __ ] one by
one
and make them [ __ ] eat it and then
put moss juice off on that [ __ ]
and then
wow i'd kick them again
ask them questions you know by that time
i'd be crying because all the pain that
they inflicted on me is finally coming
out yeah yeah but it's cathartic for a
human to do something like this
he has to know in the back of my mind
while i'm doing this i'm going to get
caught
but it's going to be well worth it i'm
going to go out of this world with that
pain that person got to see it
and not them throwing more salt on them
then i start on their genital parts
then i start carving out their [ __ ]
you know
taking their nose off more salt the
thing about an [ __ ] is the more you
cut it out the bigger the [ __ ] gets
yeah no no and then i take the 32
pop the gun up there
and that's when you just leave him there
to gurgle for [ __ ] four hours you
don't want to see that part looking like
a [ __ ] chicken cutlet you hang them
upside down so the blood leaks out of
their [ __ ] ear loads and that's it
that's how you do somebody who
did something bad to your family did
something bad to you did something bad
to a daughter a son something that's the
only way
anybody could go up and shoot you from a
car like kennedy they shot him from a
[ __ ] book tower yeah any [ __ ]
[ __ ] could do that but to just pick
somebody up by the throat and go you're
going
and guess what i'm strapping myself up
like one of these arabs as soon as the
cops hit the basement
i pulled the [ __ ] booby pair so we
all go anyway you're going you're going
yeah don't think you're not going but
[ __ ] it that's the only way to do it if
you're gonna do somebody who's just
[ __ ] with you yeah now to shoot a
[ __ ] like a one of these dummy
talent agents or
like one of these [ __ ] stupid
comedians that's easy invite them to the
comedy store and wait till they go to
the bathroom and blast them with a gun
with a silence and leave them there
yeah where's the fun of that the easiest
hit is the one that's the most obvious
look at all the great hits in time
listen the greatest hit of our time
in my eyes was john gotti on paul
castellano at stake
sparks steakhouse
you know a week before christmas at
dinner time
that's
genius
that's because you're in the chat center
of it you're in the dead center at
number one number two the only object
you have the only thing you have is an
off-duty cop
that's what you're worried about
i'm worried about an old duty cop why
where off-duty cops are the goofy ones
look what happened at [ __ ] uh
hollywood and highland the other day
some guy ripped out a knife and started
stabbing some [ __ ] family
two off-duty cops shot the guy and
sustained them and put him down off-duty
cops are everywhere
they're walking with their families a
lot of them carry a piece
but you know in that case this is paul
[ __ ] castellano walks out of a
restaurant and all of a sudden he starts
getting black remember one gun is bad
enough can you ever see that
you ever see that scene in the heat
when they rob the bank at the end they
come out to the car and give them the
money and
[ __ ] oh sees the guy and he brings out
the bazooka it's on
can you imagine that
put that scene on one night and sit
there smoke a joint and sit there and go
what would happen to my insides of that
if i ever heard that
you would drop you would definitely pee
your pants
[ __ ] would start to trickle your heart
would beat
to endless endless it's sweat endless
your that mouth goes dry that's not your
world i think i might pass out you pass
i pass on
i passed out i pass out i pass out all
the time
your heart your body can't [ __ ]
handle it
for some people who are not trained in
that that's why they send you the basic
training yeah to shoot guns to hear how
a [ __ ] machine gun sounds
so your response your reactions to that
i like these guys that buy a gun and go
on the street and they don't know
nothing about nothing
and i've seen a thousand guys i bro when
i was a kid i had a friend of mine who
went to one place and it was a shootout
and people asked the next day what
happened to your gunner
he ran out of it his girlfriend told us
years later he ran that night guys it's
a different world yeah that's why i hate
people who carry guns because
40 of them don't really know what
they're doing with them well did you see
what happened and this is what i was
worried about this woman got her purse
stolen
and these people came and this woman was
carrying a gun and shot at the dude
and it's just like that's like that's
what i'm worried about like what
oh there's [ __ ] hillbillies
i love that type of [ __ ] oh my god i
told him to stop the lady shot the
[ __ ] guy she robbed the purse yeah
did you see the tape no whatever he
stole her purse she kills him
they didn't kill him right i don't think
they killed him and i think it was
another lady had a gun hell and just
decided to shoot which i mean he did
steal a purse he's not great but yeah
but what about the judicial system which
says that you have a right to a trial
and a lawyer and you know what are
people just going to become judge jury
and executioner on the street anybody
that can pick up a gun can just decide
who lives and dies
that's [ __ ] crazy
listen man
three fridays ago you were in a town
doing comedy
and you were in your room writing
[ __ ] jokes and also the phone rang or
you looked up and somebody said did you
hear what happened in paris
and you turned the tv on
and also they started describing these
people at a [ __ ] concert these people
at a cafe
now if you didn't stop but you were
thinking at that moment for 30 seconds
and you didn't process this could happen
now now that this happened this could
happen anywhere for simmons
this could happen anywhere fitzsimmons
people are pissed
americans are scared americans are broke
i don't blame a lot of americans for
their behavior right now it's a
different country when you and i were
growing up no i do there's a way this
country behaves we have a weird
president and right now people are on
edge yeah i can't [ __ ] take my kid to
[ __ ] the mall now because
christmas shopping because these
[ __ ] are going to do this you
can't take them to school that's more
dangerous at the school than the mall
half the country
is closes we're living in a country
where half the country's voting on these
on these uh
uh uh refugees and the other half of the
country's like [ __ ] [ __ ] them
we don't want them you know we have to
put them through a strict [ __ ]
process because there might be cells
there already listen they already caught
four of them in honduras last week that
means there's 18 of them already in
california
okay you have to assume you have to
assume well you're an american and
you're educated yeah you have to assume
they're here but not just the refugees
regardless well how do you think they
got here do you think that they got here
in a red carpet premiere no they came up
to honduras they dragged like mexicans
they say whatever the [ __ ] mexicans did
they got up you know those coyotes
they'll [ __ ] eat a scab off an
iranian's [ __ ] fingernail they don't
give a [ __ ] lee so eight mexicans show
listen i come up to you i go you want to
go to the united states
see
c
tell them i'm your friend primo
before this guy got sent over he took
[ __ ] two weeks of [ __ ] spanish
what's her name rosa perez the [ __ ]
things you learned online yeah from
amazon stone rosetta stone
all right whatever [ __ ] name is she
rose that a [ __ ] stoned them
let's be educated americans here okay
and okay you're saying joy but you're
paranoia let's say okay look what they
did in paris look what they're doing
everywhere else okay
they shot down the plane yesterday so
you're telling me these people are
trying they're like colombians now you
watch you watch netflix sure i saw that
okay they had different pads going they
just don't have
this way to go to the united states they
just didn't have panama
they were shipping through mexico and it
was coming into miami and it was coming
into new york city and it was coming in
through there and it was coming in
through here and they sent in and they
accepted out of seven shipments
they knew
two of them were gonna get grabbed
it's the same mentality when i'm sending
over those [ __ ]
people to the border meanwhile you're
thinking that they're sending them in
through this refugee thing
and we're watching these refugees they
caught four of them in honduras with
fake passports right so that's my point
so do you think they're the first ones
that went through honduras that means
we've already got 18 of them here oh
okay so now what do you think we how do
you think this works
i go to a mexican family that hasn't
eaten in [ __ ] two weeks
two weeks
okay they're just poor [ __ ] mexican
people
they don't know no better
they're like the farmers in colombia who
pick the [ __ ] leaves for 10 cents a
day meanwhile the the final result is
three billion a [ __ ] year
these people are poor little [ __ ]
spicks i come up to you it's an arabian
accent
i give you [ __ ] more money you've
ever seen to teach me spanish and i'm
going to take your family to the united
states
give me some of your t-shirts give me a
[ __ ] poncho
and let's get this [ __ ] through
and they shaved their beard you tell me
half these arabs don't look like listen
on the way home today go to go to the
[ __ ]
laurel canyon and channel the [ __ ]
7-eleven look me in the face when you
walk out and tell me that's not isis in
there
what are you saying the guy that works
there the whole store
the whole store
the entire operation the entire
operation i wish this was a joke i wish
i wish that you didn't you can't let the
fear get to you like the other day it's
blinding the other day i walked in there
after the attacks and they had the arab
music blasting
they had the turbans on they were
looking at americans giggling when they
walked and i was watching them i was
looking for the hubba bubba
you think i'm trying to be funny i'm not
being [ __ ] funny so you have to alert
listen guys they're going to do
something
they're going to do [ __ ] something
and they want to do it within the next
two weeks to make a [ __ ] statement
they got this poor russian all fired up
this putin guy he's no [ __ ] genius
honestly you know and i'm not pat listen
listen guys i was prepared to die when i
was 17 years old i'm not i've never i
don't give a [ __ ] i don't vote i got
felonies i'm not going to [ __ ] about all
this [ __ ] you want me to lie to you but
i'm telling you you have to be
a little bit cautious you have to keep
your eyes open
and you got to have something you got to
have a bb gun you got to have a knife on
you you better have something
something uh
irish i love you the death that's in
your [ __ ] blood
look i think i think if you want to stop
this [ __ ] it's uh you know
you're you feed into it when you when
you can when you objectify a race of
people or a culture of people because of
some events that happen in paris
you're gonna cause animosity that could
actually lead to people it's a it's a
recruiting tool we feed into it and we
create
uh more more people that are maybe
living on the edge of the muslim society
and uh you make them hate us
we're doing the recruiting for them
you know they're innocent people
i mean i
it's they're a part you know
they're a part of america there's some
shitty ones and there's some good ones
but i really i don't think as a race
that they are responsible for more
crimes in this country and uh
you know the ones that got here before
were college students
a lot of the terrorists that came
through this country that were trained
here they were friends of the bushes
they came in here business class they
overstayed college visas the poor people
coming in they're not there don't give a
[ __ ] they got no what do they get
allegiance to a bunch of guys in [ __ ]
turbans that used to beat them with
rocks they don't give a [ __ ] about that
place they want to come to america
and we obviously like that whole thing
about
giving muslims and ids never if that
happens it's [ __ ] terrible
but they have all with all this
technology they're running background
checks on everybody behind the scenes
probably yeah you would hope
the issue i have is like i'm pretty
liberal for the most part
but i don't understand why everyone
hates like it feels like everyone hates
on the military
and the us military yeah i i feel like
it's like
anti like
people would be anti being having them
in the street like i spent six months in
israel and they're just everywhere
and at this point i'd be more
comfortable with them being in the
street
than the military yeah than than
everyone else having guns i think people
be [ __ ] miserable seeing
seeing military people all over the
place that would make that would make me
frown we turn into cuba
yeah
but we're turning into cuba but this is
happening
and every three boxes and i believe in
security
i believe in a lot of things i believe
in people looking after one another
but jesus christ if i gotta walk up the
corner and there's a tank on my [ __ ]
no i'm running a tank store what do you
think you want if you're gonna come to
protect uncle joey bring the tank
don't show up with a jeep with some
skinny guy with a cough
you know what i'm saying i'm sure they
have i i don't need no corporal you know
what i'm saying i shot the sheriff not
the deputy this is l.a i'm
sending the big guns [ __ ] this out of
the box
i don't really have a tank
there you go good call let's do this
better version eric clapton or uh bob
marley
in my world
both of them are so [ __ ] good yeah it
doesn't even matter right it's like all
along the watchtower both versions this
is dan from breyer you know dan from
irvine sure yeah
i'm doing a podcast but i'm coming down
there with three jews and a [ __ ] and
a click a [ __ ] we're counting
chairs
put it on speaker you know i love you
brother i heard what ticket sales are
good well i see you tonight
i'll see you there my friend thank you
for the call i love you bye
bye buddy looking good for brea i like
it
everyone
irvine or brad oh [ __ ]
kick that [ __ ] horsely
yeah these british guys doug the reggae
the stones they loved reagan because
they had jamaicans in london
so these guys are playing rock and
they're throwing some little upstroke
reggae sound in there
somebody told me that's what reggae
guitar playing is you don't hit it on
the down stroke you hit on the upstroke
uh
[ __ ] tremendous man yeah
for what
i don't know are you kidding me oh [ __ ]
and when i plant the seaweed
oh shitley
taking you deep in the [ __ ] murky
waters eric clapton right there
now we're living in some
we're living in weird times my friend
yes we are but we got we got kids
so you got no choice you gotta you gotta
say we're gonna we're gonna make it work
we get through it
i had a situation last night and i i
want to get your input on it i went to
see the movie and i got a little bit
high
and right as the movie started paul says
she got hit with like an eminem
and we look i was like what who's that
your girl yeah
i looked we looked back and we didn't
see anybody
else are you okay she's like i'm okay i
was like okay
and like three quarters of the way
through another one came down
it didn't hit anything
and i was a little hot but i was like
i wanted to get up and do something
and then i was like oh i was like okay i
can't get overconfident like i don't
want to like be like i'm gonna
punch somebody and then
what if they have a weapon
what if there's three of them yeah so
like i didn't know
if they kept doing it i was gonna have
to do it but they they didn't do it ever
again
and when the movie was over they were
gone but
you know who it was no but there was no
one there behind us it wasn't there was
like no one in the movie
like what would you kidding you bent
over and picked it up [ __ ]
and ate that [ __ ] and said
this is like jesus is loving me who the
[ __ ] are you kidding me
i got it i got him
let me know if it happens again you
picked that [ __ ] m up and you're like
[ __ ] g you like that you were like
that kid in the animal house when he was
jerking off to to playboy and awesome
the chick shot through his window and he
looks like he goes thanks god
[ __ ] classic scene
thanks
and the girls just drunk enough to [ __ ]
them anyway
she was gonna close
put the video on the animal house march
the kid whacking off the playboy oh my
god you forgot about that and i thought
about that and right let me tell you the
brilliance of that movie
that once she lands in what's the next
scene
is kept breaking going stop stop and
they run them over and they show kevin
bacon in the floor
all right oh my god that you understand
comedy brilliance yeah which
nobody really does no more in a film
yeah they didn't get you with just a
[ __ ] uh hook they got you with a
straight one because when kevin hook
when kevin bacon gets run over you
[ __ ] die after you're like you're
stoned you're a kid you don't know about
it you just [ __ ] fall out right then
later on you're like it wasn't that
funny but little [ __ ] like that i
remember like
[ __ ] the cake the cake float that they
built yes what did it say on the side of
it uh eat that eat me eat me
like you didn't need that but it was
there oh my god they have it no they
don't a little bit of extra no they
don't have it is that the one let me see
let's see oh my god
no no no they don't
yeah
he's not even in his zone he's in his
dad's room look at him put the music
onto it
one more time
one more time daddy
thank you
oh my god he's gonna tear that up oh my
god that kid is gonna tear it up
that
is of the funniest [ __ ] things
in his dad's room not even his own he's
gonna spunk one out right where his
mother sleeps he doesn't give a [ __ ]
that's where the magazine is
that is real comedy ladies and gentlemen
what you're seeing today is [ __ ]
that who wrote that
uh animal house was written by uh what's
his name the don't tell me ramus
don't even tell me that what's this yeah
harold remus who wrote animal house lee
i think it was produced by uh um is it
john landis yeah that whole team but it
wasn't really ramus who wrote that okay
here we go oh my god
oh jesus christ
all right so it's produced by right-wing
and simmons oh reichman right
and then what do you want you want to
see who was written
it's right up on top can be on top
jesus christ
don't make me there you go yeah rey miss
kearney and miller
[ __ ] that famous no not on board
me yeah oh he's saying he's great
he was my hero now he's my hero yeah
they didn't put him right
live and he said okay watch my heat
[ __ ] yeah watch this
watch this ain't no world hey don't
worry you don't like me it's okay you
like all my friends yeah oh yeah but you
don't like me okay my feelings ain't
hurt but watch what i'm gonna give it
i'm gonna give you this i'm gonna give
you stripes yeah and then just out of
respect let me drop ghostbusters on you
how you like me now [ __ ] yeah
and i'm going to steal i'm going to
steal your castle yes and guess what
else i don't have to give you 50 of the
take like the rest of these suckers yeah
all right how's that for you yeah right
that was what else did i see when i was
rammus oh he did it was he groundhog day
you know i got to work with him right
talk to him no [ __ ] yeah well i was wow
why is that
he was groundhog day analyze that
groundhog day should got an oscar if it
didn't dorsey
writing or directing writing
writing okay
still got the picture on my built on my
wall that was awesome i [ __ ] loved it
opens up with animal house
first movie
delta house
sctv
then goes with meatballs followed by
caddyshack followed by stripes
oh my god from 1979 to 81.
can you believe that meatballs
caddyshacks i am
[ __ ]
they have to pay him you know those
people that i love
fitzsimmons
you know what i love about fitzsimmons
he's non-threatening
but he makes me [ __ ] laugh
thanks man that's nice to hear nothing i
like more
than when white [ __ ] people got hard
irish that's a completely different type
of white people
but when i see a white dude yeah like
tommy easter
if i have a problem i'll call tom easton
talking land
and i'm gonna die but they're gonna die
with me we're gonna die with our hands
held because that's their nature yeah
they don't know no better they don't
know irish they don't know better yeah
what they said what let's go down there
yeah next thing you know you're getting
stitches and they're in the hospital i
love you man
the [ __ ] i got 18 stitches i lost a leg
and what happened exactly why are we
here because my sister the guy calls it
a stupid [ __ ]
and now i got no legs
i gotta hang out like the terrace the
australian dude who killed his
girlfriend
what's the thing but seriously
victorious what i'm just
whatever his [ __ ] name uh yeah you're
gonna have to shoot your girlfriend yeah
there's just some [ __ ] people and how
raymus had that
like i went down i [ __ ] hate latino
auditions
editions auditions oh auditions there's
nothing bothering me mom when an agent
calls me and says hey
i have a 4 30 for you when they don't
tell me what the project is and they
said i'll send them over to you bye
ah that's always a by the way
characters always named rodriguez or
garcia and i look at the [ __ ] role
and it's for some two spanish thugs
and i read it and you ever read
something as you're reading it you know
it's louis guzman
yeah like as you're reading it you know
who this is you already know who this is
the offers are already out yeah they're
just you they're just getting you for
safety they you they you have a star
attached you know who's already attached
to the film and you look at the role and
in my heart i'm like i hacked into
something else and i go you know what
i'm not going in for this [ __ ]
audition it was the one about
the [ __ ] dude who was the host of the
gong show oh
cia agent right remember that movie man
15 years ago yes
it was louis guzman in that one see as
i'm telling you as i wrote as i read the
[ __ ] thing in those days
i could see the casting
and you know what i look at the address
it's beverly hills
those places in those days they give you
a wall they treat you like a white
person they validate your parking yeah
like let me go down there it's like
december 6th or something like that
right around this time harbor
and i go in there because the christmas
stuff was up
and i remember going and i ever gonna
audition there's 80 [ __ ] animals no
my time was 3 30 and when i got there 3
30 something came out did they offer you
water
would you like a newspaper you know it
was that type of office i walk in
this lady i read threatened before i go
in i go listen i don't know why he sent
me for us
she was i'm looking at all
authenticities forget this is an
ambiguous role they tell you
i read for it and she tells me at the
end she goes it was a really good read
man she was listening i'm like a lady
they got an offer on yeah you know right
she goes listen my next movie
is you
keep me posted keep in touch with me
and i got something for you she told me
right now yeah very sweet ladies right
and that's exactly what it did i sent
her a thank you note for that i sent her
a christmas card then i shot this thing
called the mesos
the mesos is why big [ __ ] left the
sopranos he was going to abc to shoot
the mezzos the mesos was about two gay
mobsters
that had a theater and the pink pussycat
in west hollywood yeah and they had
collected money so it was going to be
two gay guys that were bears yeah those
bear type gay guys so they were brothers
but they were bare they're both gay but
they weren't going to be gay the show
was going to be on the theme on the thin
edge yeah but after [ __ ] quit the
sopranos everything went downhill
abc candid but the guys still owned it
and fox
the little fox back then now it's fox 21
fox 24 fox hindu now they had a fox for
everything yeah in those days it was fox
and a little [ __ ] fox
so the fox first fox search lab all
right fox search labs yes we'll do the
[ __ ] project perfect we shot it in
january i booked it it was a two-week
short film whatever they took it to all
these gay festivals did fantastic i sent
her a real
she calls me back she goes listen i want
you to come in new york
and read for this we'll send you a plane
ticket
come to new york then those days they
were still [ __ ] cool yeah
flying in for an audition yeah flying in
for an audition no hotel yeah which i
don't give a [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying yeah i take the freak ticket i
don't know nothing in those days greg
fitzsimmons
i know nothing about nothing okay
and finally i asked my
agent to send me everything and he sends
me the film
who the [ __ ]
uh who's in it who wrote it and it was
harry ramus
and every piece of sperm
came out of my [ __ ] and everything i
said if i booked this i could talk so
much [ __ ] yeah i got i got everybody
because nobody works with this [ __ ]
yeah this is the true market with comic
i went in there red brother they [ __ ]
called me and gave it to me right away
oh no it took about a month they took oh
they tormented me yeah and you know it
says shoot date april 24th i snapped by
the 29th and just picked up the phone
and called the casting director what is
the meaning of this yeah and i'm like
joey hold on susie ferris who today is a
big timer here in town
at that time she was an assistant for
this lady in new york
and she called me back and she goes you
booked it we'll send you this this this
and this and dog i tell you what i even
stopped doing blow for a week before
that good for you which was a lot in
those days
i'm not gonna lie it's like four days
four days
four [ __ ] days i quit doing blow
before i went in with that guy yeah he
was
everything i wanted him to be
you know who the [ __ ] am i i could lie
to you guys and tell you he was
everything i wanted him to be as a
director i don't even know what the
director was
a director to me as a guy who sits with
you and teaches you something you learn
something
and he was very good to me that day but
it was until they shot the other side
and i had his ear
for two hours just him and me new jersey
where you from you be smoked dope
and also i started asking about what
happened
and he told me montreal comedy fast so
they could suck my dick
he just started telling me the things
that didn't matter yeah
he just broke him down from me as a
comic what doesn't matter and what
matters
everything else is [ __ ] he goes so
what the guy didn't want to work with me
it was his [ __ ] loss
now look at me you know i'm saying i'm
living like a [ __ ] doctor
and i left that set a different person
yeah because i had he lifted me it's
like when you go to [ __ ] comedy
spirit greg it's not like going to the
west side comedy jam where you follow
eight guys that are bringing four people
you know yeah when you go to the comedy
store sebastian's in front of you you
know what i'm saying yeah so right off
the bat you lift up you lift up a little
bit you go from being a yellow belt to a
[ __ ] brown belt now all of a sudden
nobody's gonna give you a belt or
nothing yeah and my now that's true in
my mind the same thing had happened
to me by working with him like now again
after that i started booking [ __ ] like a
madman yeah a book spider-man 2 american
gangster long and short just from the
confidence
that he gave me that day he's like
listen nobody likes me but who gives a
[ __ ] he said that yeah oh yeah he was
cool as [ __ ] yeah he didn't give a [ __ ]
that people didn't like him that's
that's the every really successful
person that i meet out here in hollywood
doesn't [ __ ] care they date they date
women with big tits and fake lips and
you know and they're they're you know 62
and she's 24 they don't give a [ __ ] how
it looks they don't they don't care how
they talk to people you know i'm not
saying in a bad way or a good way it's
just a thing i've found is that to get
that powerful you have to truly not give
a [ __ ]
now there's two there's two schools of
thought and this is what got
me here with you
i was always happy i didn't give a [ __ ]
but it was
half routine and half i really didn't
give a [ __ ] because
and i was thinking about this today how
i look at my daughter who's two who's
three and three years old
and she's not i don't want to say i
don't know how to say this without
sounding creepy she's a virgin of life
right now when i pick her up she says
daddy and i pick her up and she always
has a good day
but someday something happens that
changes them that's why i don't like
[ __ ] dogs around my kids
that's the reason i don't want a [ __ ]
dog around i know your pitbulls great
and you you saved them from a fire
listen that's great but these
[ __ ] snap eventually especially
when they're around little kids because
little kids are like a dog
because these these little children when
they're that young
you could crack them at that age it's
not the same and even if they don't snap
pimples are just really strong dogs yeah
well whatever it's not the the point is
that you know it's like even when they
get into their first pushing match at
school
it affects them you know if a kid hits
them
it affects them
like when i was a [ __ ] up my dad died
when i was three and i've walked around
like a momo for two years
i played hooky one day i got hit in the
head with a [ __ ] flashlight and it
snapped me out of here that's who i am
today the guy that you know i got hit in
the head with a thermos
i got into a fist fight and i got hit
with a head in the thermos until today i
think to that like that
woke me up how old were you
six first grade yeah played not even
played hooky went to get a hot dog
whatever got hit that hit in the head
seeing my own blood
knowing that that could happen now makes
a different person out of you mm-hmm you
know i was sitting there going when is
it going to happen to mercy like what
kid's going to push it
down and hurt her feelings you know it
starts with something like that you know
i'm sure it's happening already
uh
but it's so weird how
when my mother died at that age when you
lose somebody close to you
and i was really catholic i really
[ __ ] believe listen look today i
believe in god i don't give a [ __ ] what
these [ __ ] think i'm gonna [ __ ] with
anybody things
god has worked for me i don't know if he
don't work for you maybe you're a piece
of [ __ ]
but you know god has worked for me in
many ways i'll let you know when we have
the time if you want to sit with me i'll
let you know eight stories how there's a
god in my life he could be jewish he
could be a [ __ ]
black dude
i don't know who the [ __ ] he is but
there's somebody who who's helped me but
when your mom gets taken away at an
early age or your dad and there's no
explanation you lose something greg yeah
and you lose that i don't give a [ __ ]
now you become a selfish i don't give a
[ __ ] for years i was a selfish i don't
give a [ __ ] you know what
what'd you say greg if i hit you in the
head with that [ __ ] microphone knock
your [ __ ] eye out let's see
and those are the people who do knock on
eye out do 30 years and you live with a
[ __ ] ipad for 30 years yeah you're
following me senseless
senseless senseless stupidity you know
you know eventually i met people and
love was brought back into my life and
stuff like that but
i never really gave a [ __ ] you know just
being spanish right there in a way i
could be one of those guys at the word
[ __ ] bothers me
or i just one day said it doesn't bother
me not giving a [ __ ]
uh it toughens your skin a little bit
yeah we have tougher skin you know how
many people have come to this town with
great aspirations greg that you came up
with get came they got a few knows
and they're back in boston working at a
bakery and now telling you some story of
them you know how it is greg we knocked
up the wife and right now
right well real estate price is a
cheaper one yeah you know i still go out
and do an open mic night every other
month when she gives me a tuesday off or
writers that you came out with that had
big aspirations and the script got shot
down
yeah yeah i was the ones that got angry
about it and said like j like uh ramus
said i'll show you i'll show you you
know and uh
what's up lee your eyes are all red you
want another inhaler is the asthma
coming back
you know what i think the asthma might
be coming back jeremy
i'm writing that down that's the next
that's my next album i'll show you
let me give some shout outs to some
people here
gordon warnock [ __ ] my main man tana
mcleave
mr luhan james edward trull's always
been around for us emily
teller brandi lynn i love you uh you
know happy [ __ ] thanksgiving with
your family your boyfriend everybody up
there
roger kelly and lol no 101 holster you
never showed up with my hoster
[ __ ] you're slipping
you're slipping
where you at this weekend great vicinity
i'm gonna be uh december 9th i'm going
to be in oklahoma snow december 9th i'm
at the comedy store in l.a doing my
500th episode of fitzdog radio joe
rogan's going to hang out with me for a
little bit we're going to shoot the [ __ ]
talk about 500 go back over each one for
an hour
so that's december 9th and then i'm in
oklahoma city at a place uh i think at
the oklahoma's
something which by the way is a [ __ ]
tremendous room oh really tremendous
people
tremendous [ __ ] hotel it's a [ __ ]
room filled with savages no [ __ ] savages
i went and loved every [ __ ] minute
i'm looking to go back next year
tremendously
psyched all right savages there
they cheer they jump up and down you can
get dirty with them [ __ ] they take
the ride they're beautiful [ __ ] the
bible belt yeah beautiful i hadn't heard
anything about the room i'm psyched
all right so we got that and then we've
got new year's eve in portland oregon at
the helium comedy club more [ __ ]
savages who i love last time i went up
there came back with a pound and a half
of [ __ ] reefer liquid acid oh yeah
it's legal bmp
i came back with everything but sugar in
the juice
i came back with [ __ ] and right
downstairs i got a beautiful medical
marijuana store named pharma yeah
f-a-r-m-a okay [ __ ] great people go
downstairs say hello they got everything
you don't need a license you don't need
anything nothing you need your driver's
license tell them [ __ ] uncle joey
sent you i don't know nothing about no
who's uncle joey don't worry it's like
white powder ma i don't know
tell them uncle joey sent you and then
they say who's on the jelly and then you
say never mind yeah i remember once you
don't need to know that
when i was 12. those are the questions
that's
bumped into me i was at uh what's the
coffee shop we're going to you know
dunkin donuts starbucks the ones
and we're sitting there in my own
business and somebody's told me and he
goes you know
he has to tell listen i i listen to the
podcast and he goes you remind me my
uncle vito you know
you can never get a [ __ ] straight
answer out of them you know never it was
always
it's not that they're bad guys yes that
and it's like that scene that's how i
was raised the perfect scene when i was
a kid we would get raided all the time
my mom had a bookmaking joint right so
every saturday
i worked the bookmaking but part of my
job was look out you look at cars who's
sitting in the car why is that car there
why is that dude you just learn how to
photograph
scenarios and who's out of place
those old school neighborhoods it's not
who's there it's who's out of place yeah
that dude wasn't there last week and
those neighborhoods they're all school
[ __ ] and you know
black people and chinese and white irish
people they don't move that's their spot
that's been their spot for 30 [ __ ]
years yeah how many bars do you go to in
boston that's mel's chair who the [ __ ]
is mel mel's been coming there don't
don't be in that chair at 505 when mel
comes in here mel's been sitting in that
scene it's something about who we are
so you learn to see not who's there but
who's out of place right so i used to
work at this place
and i remember that the cops would tell
you when they were going to come
to raid you someone said you having ten
thousand have fourteen hundred let us
take something in
you know what i'm saying yeah and in
those days a lot of people don't know
this book making is a ticket in new york
city yeah it's a felony in new jersey i
think it's a ticket new york city yeah
they give you a ticket they give you a
fine they take 400 off the table
whatever but it's so weird how
you learn how the lingo because
everything you say is used against you
everything you say is used against you
a lot of people don't realize that [ __ ]
there's one cop that's sitting and
there's one cops that's listening as
soon as you get in the car while you say
no your handcuffs on he's writing
something what the [ __ ] do you think
he's writing what the [ __ ] you just said
remembering good fellas when he pinches
the kid on the street selling cigarettes
yeah what's he say to him
it's all right
yeah
it's all right
come on kid who's it he's it's all right
it's going to be a
it's all right
he didn't say his name
who he was with
that's it you [ __ ] it's amazing how
many times i got arrested
and i would throw them the [ __ ] off with
like a couple [ __ ] words
because they weren't used to that [ __ ]
yeah
they were used to people talking
and you're still talking but you ain't
saying nothing drives people [ __ ]
nuts
so what do you do
it's like jiu-jitsu it's like a it's
like verbal jiu-jitsu you're not you're
not committing your weight in any one
direction you're balanced you're right
in the center you're in your own weight
and then you can you can go any
direction any time
what are you doing for thanksgiving you
still didn't bring the [ __ ] turkey
over there did you
no they're gonna eat chickens yeah
that's what you want for thanksgiving
sure what the [ __ ] is wrong with that
chicken this is what i got to deal with
chicken on thanksgiving i said to him
was instead of being rude
ralph's gives you a [ __ ] turkey if
you spend over 50 bucks free turkey
this [ __ ] moulage i go get the
[ __ ] turkey bring it over and say
they gave it to me i can't do nothing
with it ma
why don't you make it for thanksgiving
very innocently he can't even [ __ ]
sell that now he's stuck eating chicken
like like a [ __ ] white boston market
they have a family thing they do who
gives a [ __ ] with the family you're the
new white [ __ ] girl right change the
rules the market is forcing so next year
i'll do it this is
there ain't going to be no next year
you're [ __ ] this year today you got
24 hours you got to play tonight go over
there with the [ __ ] turkey and go i
just got this at rouse
i can't do nothing with it let's [ __ ]
cook it up and she's she's [ __ ]
mexican they love that [ __ ] tell you
take those chickens down to the laugh
factory give them the homeless yeah give
those birds
pigeons from el barrio give those
[ __ ] things away eat turkey it's a
family thing who gives a [ __ ] so is
[ __ ] cancer you know what i'm saying
it's a family [ __ ] thing too he just
calls your dinner
cancer yeah a chicken
a chicken is something on the side
chicken is the thing you have the night
before yeah come on you've had some dry
ass turkey i'm having mexican chicken
covered in bacon with salsa verde it's
so you're selling your [ __ ]
everything you got american
for some chicken
with bacon and salsa [ __ ] birdie
there's people who eat fish it doesn't
matter there's [ __ ] generations i
have turkey at some point what [ __ ]
you gotta have it tomorrow first meal up
dog that's tradition because it's a
thursday night
you came over here to have a better life
not for you to eat a [ __ ] chicken
with bacon on it you [ __ ] you understand
me it is it's insulting to you it's just
something to everybody
it's insulting to everybody now i
understand it's a tradition you know
what my tradition is on [ __ ]
thanksgiving day having somebody lick my
[ __ ] with a coke rock in it that's my
tradition i wish i could do that for
thanksgiving just go into what's that
happy baby yoga position yeah and have a
hot chinese chick come over and just put
little rocks in my [ __ ] and suck it
and jerk my [ __ ] dick off that's my
tradition i would love to do that for
thanksgiving you think i want to hang
out with white people and pray and hear
boring [ __ ] stories but guess what
you gotta eat a turkey on thanksgiving
so don't offend me no more right when
you leave here go over the [ __ ] just
buy one and bring one over there and go
listen they gave me this what do you
want me to do so just for the record
late
you eating chicken on thanksgiving is
cancer who's cancer you eating turkey on
thanksgiving is a coke rock in your
[ __ ] while an asian girl eats it out
and jerks you off that's what you want
on thank you that's not even close not
even close experiences that's my [ __ ]
i wasn't i wasn't going to tell this
story but i felt now it kind of matches
up now
you had joey on your podcast and radio
show a couple years ago and you had me
on
and i think about this all the time you
asked me a question that i think about
constantly he said what's the hardest
part about working with joey diaz
and i said something stupid like oh it's
all fun
and i was like that this part is the
hardest part
and i'll be telling you the truth
what's the [ __ ] truth chicken who
cares
who cares it's chicken
it's not about what you eat there's
families whatever
two thousand years ago
these [ __ ] white momos
were hanging out minding their own
business with these [ __ ] hats on
these [ __ ] little suits on like the
magma like the jacksons in the 60s
with tights on
and they had nothing some people had
corn
some people had whatever the [ __ ] they
were turkey some people had nay some
people had bread and also boom the
horizon they saw some indians
not on the gen any other [ __ ] day of
the week
i'd have to stab those [ __ ] but
these guys they seem like friendly
people
you know what i'm saying sometimes you
shoot a black guy like that [ __ ] dude
in chicago how many times you shoot that
boy 14 in the jesus christ
unfucking believable he's gonna die in
that and oh he's going to die in jail
and uh they said [ __ ] it
you want to come over and eat
and the [ __ ] people say well we got
some of this and we got some of that
well what can we get can we get a
[ __ ] chicken or a pigeon they said no
it's not enough for all of us
but if we make a few turkeys all 30 of
us could [ __ ] eat
and all of a sudden every year people
started [ __ ] doing their turkeys
you following me it was a thousand years
ago whatever the [ __ ] it happened i'm
not good with dates
the point of the story is
let me tell you something let me tell
you something about my world one of my
tightest friends in the world is a girl
by my name is stacy pocaluda do you know
who stacy bocaluda is now she's a comedy
publicist i love stacy very much
i went to a house one year which was
already a taboo because she had
thanksgiving at six o'clock that's
always a bad sign
i'm a pot smoker get that turkey ready
by two three yeah read the [ __ ]
latest right and i'm talking well you
that turkey better be [ __ ] sliced at
three don't bring it to the table at 3
30 and i got to eat [ __ ] potatoes and
bread i have a [ __ ] [ __ ]
two is two two o'clock because you're
going to take another pass at it there's
a rematch at around 10 o'clock at night
and whose world is that you're talking
about seven o'clock i'm talking about 5
15. yeah you know if you eat at two
you're making a white you're making a
[ __ ] turkey on wonder bread
by five o'clock and you're in my room
i'm getting you high
right or wrong after that turkey
are you eating are you smoking between
courses
smoking i'm smoking all day tomorrow on
periscope
i might even go to church tomorrow
morning and smoke right in front of
[ __ ] church on periscope just to let
these [ __ ] know how it's done
i love
anyway back to stacey buckaluda
i waited i held that all [ __ ] day and
i went up there at six for starters
she gave me [ __ ] box mashed potatoes
that's one of the worst mashed potatoes
i've ever had in my life
if anybody knows me and anybody knows
anything about me
i'm so sensitive that i was drawn to
tears and i'm not ashamed to say this i
was very upset that i was so upset
that i got home went to bed and my wife
woke me at three in the morning
she said she knew how upset i was that
she made the turkey mashed potatoes and
stuffing and i got up took a shower
drank coffee smoked the joint and ate
turkey till six in the morning that's
because my wife your wife did that for
you that's how serious she was that's
beautiful the moral of the story was i
didn't talk to stacy for eight [ __ ]
months she kept calling me she didn't
know why and one night i had to say you
know why stacy because you made the
worst mashed potatoes i've ever had in
my life on thanksgiving night
wow and out of all the nights to make a
[ __ ] bad mashed potato right it's not
that [ __ ] night okay right if you
don't know something don't [ __ ] do it
call somebody who does know it's
thanksgiving don't [ __ ] nothing up so i
take thanksgiving very [ __ ]
personally right
it's not that i'm going off on you so
please don't even stand in other words
once we leave here go to ross and get a
chicken please a turkey and bring it
over there tonight
unannounced
unannounced ring the [ __ ] bell
go upstairs and go mom i love you you're
not gonna believe what happened and get
some flowers too go for the [ __ ]
small 50
and stop being a [ __ ] head all your life
let's put our foot down now so everybody
knows that lisa exists before you become
that white [ __ ] son-in-law in the
corner and nobody talks then you're like
and you got the head
go over there tonight get the [ __ ]
turkey and the [ __ ] flowers and you
bring them over to the mom and say mom
potatoes
yeah just so there's no
misunderstandings and you go here they
gave me this around so i'm [ __ ]
embarrassed but it doesn't fit in my
freeze and i don't know what to do with
it why don't you make it tomorrow give
her a kiss and walk out don't say what
yeah
say why don't you make it tomorrow and
kiss it and turn around and walk away
and when you get there tomorrow two
o'clock you bet your ass don't be a
[ __ ] turkey there could be a chicken
it's a baby you never asked you assumed
the clothes
she's spanish they love cooking
bring the [ __ ] turkey over there lee
because if not you're going to upset me
very much
not as much as yesterday when you went
to [ __ ] subway after the nice workout
we had
subway bad
i said it's more low fat than mcdonald's
this [ __ ] guy did a tremendous
kettlebell workout he was just getting
61 [ __ ] pounds i didn't even pick up
61 pounds yesterday for how long [ __ ]
for an hour we go every tuesday do you
do uh aerobic as well or is it just we
just wait we do [ __ ]
10 for 15. we do 10 for 15 kettlebells
then we do cleans we did squats
yesterday sometimes we do the ropes but
i go there every tuesday but i have
kettlebells in my trunk and then i doing
one day in front of the house yeah then
when i go on the road friday inside i
just lift weights in the hotel there we
go dumbbells and an elliptical cell yeah
that's what i try to do and i go to one
or two jiu-jitsu's tomorrow we're going
to jujitsu you taking lee yeah
for a few months no [ __ ] lee's going on
a competition next week that's why
this [ __ ] is really yeah and
then i'm taking them saturday at one
o'clock to higgins
we're going to higgins one morning if he
can found out we're going to take you to
higgins bring your ghee the sanibel and
my cousins in town julio rodriguez he's
teaching at eagans at 11 o'clock on
saturday let's go down there [ __ ] yeah
lee you getting ready dog
this is it [ __ ] okay let's do it
he sounds enthused
he loves you know once he gets there bro
he's good is he an animal oh listen he's
got this foot he inherits see those jews
from auschwitz yeah over the years this
uh what's the thing that they got in
their systems the
the the chromosome whatever the [ __ ]
they got well anyway that's what they
got the thai sacks a [ __ ] foot he's
got a foot he's
heavy and short so it's not like joe
diaz laying on you that i could roll you
like a [ __ ] bowling ball you can't
roll you at all you're heaviest don't
don't be saying that [ __ ] you threw me
off you the other day i know he just
gasses out because instead of pulling me
down he wants to [ __ ] judo throwing
me and then he pulls up that little
alligator full of his you know what do
you mean what's what kind of foot like
we both start on our knees yeah we're
both even but um if he gets on his
[ __ ] feet he's my height it's
hysterical all right so to tip me over
he picks up that little jew club and he
[ __ ] throws me down because he's got
the strength of ten [ __ ] hercules
does he look at him and he wrestled in
high school he's one of these guys
that's uh
he's uh he doesn't know he has no
[ __ ] idea what he's doing yeah every
time i'm wrestling all you hear is me
going
because every time he moves one day i
had him in a half guard he stuck his
foot like jewish people the club from
auschwitz i didn't know this about him
what do they got chromosomes not that
how do they get people dna right they
got good dna in their feet and they
[ __ ] open heat when his feet go down
on you they cut you nobody has ever
broken my i had a [ __ ] purple thing
inside my thigh yeah
lee
holy [ __ ] i would have never guessed
that but i got a dress offense it just
you don't look like uh i got today like
an athlete no this is the first time
i've worked out in my life we i gotta
drag him because if i don't drag him
once he gets there he's johnny hercules
yeah
like the other day i'm watching him he
starts swinging the 61 pounds and this
is what i like about people
there's some people that you got to take
to the dance i want to thank those you
know it's like these guys i say well
she's not going to suck my dick
take it for the steak dinner
you never know you give it a steak give
me the tiramisu
a glass of white wine she might have a
different tune you know what i'm saying
they never want to suck dick somebody
got to talk them into it right no woman
woke up one morning and said you know
what today i want to suck a dick
every woman had to get talked into
sucking that first dick right who do you
think and then you know i had a guy for
a friend of mine
in high school told me this that he
dated a girl for four years till college
she never sucked his dick and she
married his friend and they were they
got divorced years later and he asked
him how good was lisa's blow job and
he's like what are you talking about she
wouldn't do it he goes what are you
kidding me i had her blowing me [ __ ]
everywhere in cars eating my ass right
it's like that girl that everybody [ __ ]
in high school but she won't [ __ ] you i
had that girl we all have yeah you took
a whole [ __ ] everybody except me i
was the friend you busted out the wine
glass your father's wine glass and
they're like oh no i'm not that type of
girl and you played along for a while
right until the end of the night when
she's heading out and going you know
what you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] everybody
[ __ ] in the ass you dirty [ __ ] get
out of my eyes hold on i'm not gonna go
to that who gives a [ __ ]
welcome to the thanksgiving podcast
thankful for
don't forget that turkey [ __ ]
remember that's wrong ricky don't lose
my number
ricky don't forget about me bring the
turkey over you gotta set your mark and
enforce it you don't want to be the
third son-in-law in the back of the room
like a [ __ ] mama luke i'm not but am
i gonna bring a turkey over there you
live near your mom no she lives in
boston
oh so she's in town no no his
mother-in-law and his mother
she lives nearby yeah they're spanish
they love to [ __ ] cook there's four
of them they're gonna make chickens
how many chickens you're gonna make
bring a [ __ ] turkey over and get the
party started
i don't care why you so scared i'm not
scared yes you are this is not about i
don't like tank you either scab off a
[ __ ] foot you eat turkey from [ __ ]
subway
yeah that means you'll eat anything yeah
right so stop it don't say that i i
don't like to eat thank you
stop bullshitting me turkey's fine you
got to set your money back force it oh
bro what what i had i moved here i had a
lot of
where i didn't have anybody to have it
with
i would much i now i'm having it with
this girl i've been dating for two and a
half years i don't give a [ __ ] i really
don't
i don't care
i'll eat turkey at some point or maybe i
won't
like this boyfriend it doesn't matter to
me
can you believe this [ __ ] why the why
did why does this turkey matter
because it matters you gotta have it
it's [ __ ] america
it's america you gotta make sense
you gotta set your mark and enforce it
that's it they're going to eat chicken
every [ __ ] year you got to bring a
turkey over she's going to cook anywhere
she's a great cook she loves to cook
bring the [ __ ] turkey over there and
set the rules for next year
you believe what i gotta do yeah but
that doesn't take like eight hours it
takes like eight hours you set it up in
the morning it's not eight it's maybe
six hours
you throw it in the morning and it's a
whole day together it's not just about
eating the turkey it's about the process
you stuff it you clean it you tie its
little [ __ ] legs together and then
you and then you wait and the house
starts to smell like turkey and you
watch some football you [ __ ] around with
your girlfriend in the other room for a
little while whatever it takes i know
you you're gonna get high and and you're
just gonna keep smelling that turkey as
you get high and hungry and then that
[ __ ] comes out and it's got wet
stuffing coming out of its [ __ ] and you
eat that and you get some real mashed
potatoes and you get some sweet potatoes
you put gravy on all of it
and then you just say this is this is a
lot to be thankful for
i also want to thank my man dante
garzini for the beautiful cards savage
dad
i can mail these out to all my prison
friends i have a few have a prison pen
pal
taking one of those home with me it's
going on the fridge
i need you to sign it i need you to
write a note on it i'm going to write
happy holidays to my main irish from the
heart
absolutely
it's a beautiful picture joey you can
see the love
something about pictures of people from
behind as they're walking hand in hand
that doesn't
that doesn't get tired i love that
i get a nice picture my
my wife my two kids holding both their
hands walking away it's one of my
favorite pictures
i got to get out the cards because joey
you reminded me that you got to send
those [ __ ] cards out to people you
know i sent it out to family and they
were all touched friends sometimes you
don't talk to a friend all year but they
get that card from you and it's like
you're still in touch
listen a card or letter it says a lot
yeah it says you took the time you had
to lick the [ __ ] stamp right how many
people even have a [ __ ] stamp in the
house
stamps.com
people don't have stamps in illinois you
know
you gotta lick i i love writing that
dude letters in jail yeah like i don't
write them every week but i wrote them
for thanksgiving to keep his chin up you
know it's so weird how
when you're locked up you're like oh
this is going to be the worst week of my
life you know what
my thanksgiving in prison was [ __ ]
tremendous because it was so [ __ ]
yeah stove top
mashed potatoes and white turkey i'm in
yeah i don't want no more i don't want
nothing once i go to your house and i
see walnuts and grape nuts and i got
this recipe from the pilgrims cactus and
octopus blood and the stuffing i gotta
go okay that's why i have my wife make
that early
so when we go out tomorrow night there's
no
so you always go to people's houses they
want to don't we put pork chops one year
we went from somebody's house they put a
turkey
with a [ __ ] pig in a [ __ ] lizard's
ass what do they do that's your duncan
oh yeah they put a [ __ ] cha
they put a duck in a [ __ ] turkey with
sausage yeah and i saw that dark meat
from the duck oh my god
i had that's the dag that's the year i
cried that was the worst i'm telling i
didn't talk to stacey for eight months
dog eight months i ate a thanksgiving
with some friends we usually do family
we did a friend's thing this year
and we go over there and i bring two
turkeys we go to ralph's i got my two
turkeys i spent 50 bucks one time i went
back the next day spent 50 bucks i got
two turkeys
bring them over the house stick them in
the oven spend the day together they
serve the meal
too much food there's not not that many
people show up there's an untouched
turkey at the end of the meal
we go to leave
and we're waiting for a plate
and they they give us uh some mashed
potatoes some sweet potatoes some uh
brussels sprouts
and i think there must be another plate
because there's no turkey on here
and uh they didn't offer any turkey they
kept the turkey kept the whole [ __ ]
thing
sent us home with nothing and i i didn't
talk to that guy for a little while
[ __ ] i'm savages
so that was the guy from irvine yeah the
general man his name was dan he used to
ram run bright yeah he's back and forth
now but it's hysterical
ever since we've been going with this
deal back and forth
i kept telling listen i don't want no
[ __ ] drum i'm showing up with two
jews with calculators that night to
count the chairs you guys say there's
500 chairs in there but there's really
581
and that one that's 20 [ __ ] but you
know what i'm saying like they don't
understand people on this you know
uh
so this morning i call them i'm like not
only do i have one i got three jews
going down there it's like a [ __ ]
three-camera shoot you know what i'm
saying
i got clickers coming from everywhere
those numbers better match up [ __ ]
right he called back to say i don't care
if you have people with clickers down
there now we got them sweating we got
the guy with the clicker down there you
gotta do those [ __ ]
i did a club in florida i won't say
which club and uh yeah the contract said
340
was in maximum combat because just so
people know we get paid bonuses when we
hit sellouts
and the sellout then should be according
to the contract 340 seats that's what it
says is the maximum in the room i get
there the place is almost completely
full they tell me the next time i didn't
hit the bonus i go let's go count the
chairs right now because i counted 435
chairs you said 350. that's 85. you're
telling me there was 85 empty chairs
last night
and oh it starts [ __ ] stuttering and
yeah we don't have to count the chairs
you know sometimes we add chairs when
there's they were left over from last
week
give me the bonus and we're good so he
gave me the bonus
sure
but can you imagine 80 [ __ ] chairs
that are trying to pretend aren't there
that's you guys know at home that it's
not just a catwalk we show up there and
they want to give you your money
even at the end they give you [ __ ]
fake figures yeah
that's why i'm bringing you tonight
[ __ ] my main [ __ ] jewel over there
you're coming down late oh yeah he's got
that [ __ ] eye of death dead
three clickers in my pocket this
[ __ ] could see a penny under a
carpet
he's got 3d vision he just looks at the
room
he closes his eyes and tells me a number
and he's five off that's how good this
[ __ ] is
so you do stand up at all you just uh
yeah yeah you just hang out at the show
and i don't really go to shows that
often i go to shows locally but yeah uh
just do this the podcast you're gonna
have a ride down to irvine tonight kids
it's going to be thanksgiving i'm saying
traffic wise thanksgiving wednesday
driving down the 405
at what 7 6 30 6 30. oh can we take the
five is it possible it doesn't matter
what you take you're you're staring at a
[ __ ] bumper you get your you're gonna
have your ways out your waze app out
trying to tell you some magical route to
take
there's no there's no way to take
getting listen we got the vaporizers
right we got the put on fits dog radio
you listen to a couple episodes we got a
full tank of gas permission from god all
right you got a lot to talk about what
he says we got a half a tank of gas a
full pack of cigarettes it's dark out
and we're wearing sunglasses
hit it and want a mission from [ __ ]
god lisa let me do the sponsors and get
the [ __ ] out of here that's it
it's a beautiful [ __ ] day man hey man
the bottom of the church is hard i know
greg feels the same way happy
thanksgiving to everybody who watches
the show
who listens we're thankful for you we're
thankful for you believe it or not and
i'll tell you what i'm thankful for
that i went to the gym this morning and
i wore my me undies i don't know if you
people know dick about me on these but
let me break it down for you right
me and these are these underwear that
are as comfortable as can be and i hate
traditional white underwear that's why i
went commando after years but once i
established me undies i went back to
wearing underwear especially when i go
to the gym because when you usually go
to jiu jitsu and stuff when you're
wrestling yeah
your [ __ ] nut pops out and then you
gotta wrestle with a nut out you know
how many times i squish my nut i don't
need the aggravation in my life i'm sick
and tired of that white thing you know i
want my i want my [ __ ] underwears to
be comfy i don't even know where to
start to be honest with you but if you
don't just want to wear underwear comfy
you want to wear the world's most
comfortable underwear
that's what me on these comes in all
right every pair of me on these is made
with microphones
which doesn't sound sexy but once you
feel me undies you'll never go back to
regular whole underwear again with me on
these you'll feel more comfortable than
ever before me on these has a ton of
different colors to choose from it's the
only place where you find styles for
both men and women mixing mats plus they
change designs every month and with the
holidays around the corner oh [ __ ] me on
these is coming to your [ __ ] mailbox
all right now trust me
these are not your parents stocking
stuffers do me a favor let's start from
the scratch go to the undies.com right
now take a look at the great selection
underwear men's
t-shirts
long underwear buy some women's
underwear throw those on saturday night
that's right what do you care
you know take a chance cuz this off
they're probably coming they're soft as
hell this is the best panel on the way
you'll ever have but don't [ __ ] try
you know whatever go to mendez.com right
now this is what i'm gonna offer you
right now for the holidays i'm gonna
give you 20 off your your first order
plus all the orders in the u.s and
canada boom on the cuff on the arm we
even have a money-back guarantee of me
on these so if you don't love your first
pair of me undies you get to keep them
in a full refund refund refund i don't
even know what refund is refund refund
so i'm sorry about that so you have
nothing to lose order before december
13th and yummy undies will arrive before
christmas again
order before the 13th
and you'll get them before christmas and
for the first 20 percent off your first
order of the world's most comfortable
underwears go to meanders.com
joey that's me undies.com slash joey
you're not going to be sorry the great
underwear listen last week i didn't tell
you about this but let me drop it on you
right now
a lot of you people you're [ __ ]
lonely you're a half a month you don't
know what to do with your life
you know
you know you work all [ __ ] day the
last thing you want to do after work is
go stand online you know you go to some
fast food joint
and you got to go home and cook some
complicated meal and it's expensive
unhealthy takeout is even any better
that's where a new service blue apron
comes in
blue apron delivers farm fresh
ingredients and step-by-step recipes
right to your home allowing you to
create a healthy hand-crafted meal
without going to the grocery store bro
it comes right to your door it's
phenomenal it comes in a box it's
refrigerated and it's for less than ten
dollars blue apron sends you fresh
ingredients perfectly proportioned i
mean to the [ __ ] tea all you gotta do
is put them in there
it makes cooking more healthy and it's
easy and fun no trips to the grocery
store no you forgot this i forgot that
nothing everything is in that box all
right and you don't waste no time with
unused ingredients plus you know how to
cook
who's better than you you know with
specialty ingredients that are normally
hard to find blue apron is perfect for
date night you meet some chick at the
mall you want to get it back to your
place you want to seduce it
[ __ ] how do you want to get to a
pants through food boom there you go
it's perfect for a date night cooking
with friends and they even they even
offer family plans with kid-friendly
ingredients so if your kids are half of
schmoe he's allergic to peanuts [ __ ] him
we got something to take care of
so the whole family could eat well and
have fun preparing meals together
each balanced meal is 500 to 700
calories per serving and this food is
tasty as hell man
let me tell you what they got next week
[ __ ]
they got you
next week they got crispy crap catfish
ramen all right that's what they got
next week the family plant they got
seared cod with garlic ginger rice and
they got listen to this pork chops with
uh mostarda sweet potatoes with walnuts
and blue cheese on them i'm hungry i'm
telling you blue aprons don't mess
around each meal is seven 500 to 700
calories per serving i'm not telling you
this and they don't send the same meal
twice so listen i know you're busy
you get home next you know you're
ordering [ __ ] food no more they work
around your schedule and dietary
preferences and blue apron experts
source only the best seasonal
ingredients for incredible meals like i
told you who's better than you when was
the last time you cooked a chili rub
steak when was the last time you cook a
seared cod with garlic ginger rice never
so give it a shot you're going to cook
incredible meals and you'll be blown
away by the quality and the freshness
blue apron it's a better way to cook
i'll tell you what i'm going to do for
you for christmas uncle jerry right now
i'm going to give you two meals on the
arm for free gratis go to blueapron.com
joey my treat i'm telling you do meals
on me when you go to blueapron.com
joey all right
also on it always on it you're traveling
shroom tech immune you you want more uh
conditioning when you when you do
aerobics or you want to breathe better
shroom tech sport you want to make a
protein powder that doesn't you know you
don't need 50 grams of protein your body
can't assimilate it two scoops a hemp
protein
32 grams of protein but listen who the
[ __ ] am i to sit here and tell you
what's crack i like it go to honor.com
right now and press in church boom and
get 10 off your first order and they
have to stay on the program they also
have kettlebells and supplements they
have an array of great things but listen
who the [ __ ] am i to tell you go to
honor.com right now and take a look at
the superb
list of
supplements they have available to you
right now that's honest.com so again
happy thanksgiving i want to uh reach
out to the blue apron on it and me
undies and thank them for supporting the
show and my main man
greg fitz for coming on and having a
blast with us thanks brother happy
holidays it was a [ __ ] blessing
i laughed my ass off today i haven't
laughed that hard in a long [ __ ] time
i'm real laughing at that fake [ __ ]
tv [ __ ] you people are using that
[ __ ] kid flying in the window an
animal house dropping on him lisa yeah
this show is brought to you by blue
apron
he sounds like he sounds like he's in
pakistan giving a hostage message look
at this [ __ ] they get a rifle to his
head
say it
say it infidel
blue airprints gourmet recipes and all
the fresh ingredients you need to make
them right to your door our listeners
get their first two meals for free just
go to blueapron.com joey and start
cooking incredible meals at home with
blue apron that's blueapron.com
joey
look at the camera when you're talking
take your time lee don't worry about
numb we got all [ __ ] night we do
you wanna know this is also brought to
you by meows.com go to mandys.com
i'm here under my own free will
i promise
how are you going to drive to irvine i'm
not you're going to captain kirk of the
enterprise no i'm not
all i know is give me a 20 minute head
start
i'm captain kirk of the uber then
um
okay go to mandy.com joey and look at
all their great
world's most com world's most
comfortable underwear
at meundies.com joey
every pair of my undies is made with
micro modal fabric
which doesn't sound sexy but once you
feel your me undies you you'll never go
back to old underwear did you just read
all this yes i don't know why he's doing
that i don't know why are you doing the
whole thing
close the goddamn show where are you for
christ's sake okay thank me undies dank
on it and thank the other people let's
boogie with stu for christ's [ __ ]
sake you're lullabying these people of
death and get out of here and go get
that turkey before six o'clock that's it
no more [ __ ] around today
ralph's bringing you thanksgiving year
after year that's right they give you